clothes and other items for Israelis
who've had to flee their homes close to
the border with
Gaza thousands have come here to the
city of aat in southern Israel to escape
the war Angel oppenheim Works in a
diving center nearby and is now a
volunteer in this distribution center
everyone here are working for free we
get no money 14 hours a day everything
is Don notion donation the the
government didn't give it money for
everyone this situation was not supposed
to happen I from the beginning I didn't
believe in this government a l is on the
shores of the Red Sea a tourist
destination that is now providing
shelter to people from the communities
affected by hamama October 7 attacks in
Israel hotels here are working at full
capacity the government says that more
than 200,000 people have been told to
leave their homes across Israel and
there won't be enough rooms for everyone
if the ground Invasion worsens the
situation aot is overwhelmed with people
evacuated from other parts of the
country that's why the local government
is setting up a plan to build a tent
city for 60,000 people this could be one
of the locations it would have a medical
facility but also a school in case the
conflict continues to escalate only in
the Border elila came from mus Kuma near
the border from Gaza she says
Palestinian Fighters did not enter her
community because they were stopped at
the entrance she's now here trying to
help children cope with trauma I came
here H to feel that I do something for
someone else and feel alive because it's
hard all the time all day H look at the
TV and the news and Instagram and all of
this
and I went to f i do something because
we need continue I don't know how but we
need continue just like millions of
people she was deeply shaken by the
attacks more than two weeks ago I won't
believe in peace I believed in the past
in peace but now I don't know if it's
possible because I feel it like
it's us or them and so I don't know what
well but something need to change you
know Israel has already moved hundreds
of thousands of soldiers and hundreds of
Tanks to the border with Gaza ahead of a
planned ground Invasion people here say
they don't know why that's not happened
yet and they're getting ready for the
next stage of the war there is alj aat
Southern
Israel make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer